jacky bonnemains bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
après 40 ans d'activité la chine
interdit donc l'importation de tout
déchet solide sur son territoire c'est
le marché mondial du recyclage qui est
donc chamboulé
qu'est ce qui va changer notamment chez
les pays les plus riches qui envoyaient
leurs déchets en chine et bien ce qui va
changer dans un premier temps c'est que
les pays riches donc producteurs de
déchets innombrables vont essayer de
trouver des débouchés
hors chine ils ont commencé par les
envoyez donc comme vous l'avez dit dans
le sud est asiatique en malaisie au
vietnam en thaïlande mais ces pays
commence à être très réticents voire
hostiles et commence symboliquement à
renvoyer quelques dizaines de conteneurs
dans les pays d'origine
on observe que maintenant l'union
européenne riche c'est à dire
l'allemagne les pays bas la france la
belgique par exemple envoient désormais
des déchets dans des pays pauvres de
l'union européenne comme comme la
roumanie ou hors union européenne en
turquie le problème avec les déchets
c'est que ça peut être considéré comme
une d'une certaine manière comme la
maladie des pays riches et c'est une
marée inéluctable qui doit se déverser
quelque part et on a observé d'ailleurs
chez robin des bois
chez robin des bois oui cet été que des
déchets partent et d'italie pour aller
se faire soit disant recyclés en tunisie
donc le problème majeur dans un second
temps c'est que l'union européenne va
devoir enfin se doter d'une véritable
industrie de recyclage et de
revalorisation de ces matières usagers
en matière secondaire réutilisables et
ça ça n'a pas été fait justement parce
que il y avait cette facilité d'envoyer
les déchets en chine
oui parce que est effectivement déjà en
janvier 2018 la chine avait fermé ses
portes à 24 catégories de déchets
solides dont certains plastiques papier
textile
voyez ce que disait alors arnaud brunet
c'est le directeur du bureau
international du recyclage basée à
bruxelles
c'est un séisme et on a toujours longue
de choc cela a mis notre industrie en
situation de stress car la chine est
tout simplement le premier marché
mondial pour l'exportation de matières
recyclables
alors du coup depuis 2018
est ce qu'on sait comment ces déchets
ont été traités par les pays occidentaux
alors quand le type de l'union
européenne dit c'est un séisme
c'est pas vrai les séismes sont d'une
certaine manière imprévisible et ce choc
du refus de la chine d'accepter des
déchets était prévisible et donc c'est
pas un tremblement de terre ce quelque
chose qui aurait dû être anticipé qui
n'a pas été fait et donc pour l'instant
on note une arrivée importante de
déchets dans les décharges que ce soit
aux états unis qui sont aussi de gros
exportateur vers la chine au royaume uni
et est en france mais aussi dans les
incinérateurs et après cette période de
transition
on espère que une industrie véritable
industrie du duo cyclage sera mise en
place dans l'union européenne
ce qu'on constate aussi si vous le
permettez c'est la faillite
de la convention de bâle sur le
transferts transfrontaliers de déchets
qui devait mettre un holà sur ces
trafics planétaire internationaux et qui
a baissé les bras il suffisait en effet
que le pays importateur disent oui j'ai
des moyens de recycler pour que le pays
exportateurs et le droit de le faire
or il n'avait pas les moyens de le faire
quand on voit les villages poubelles les
villages poubelle donc les risques
sanitaires pour tous ceux qui tripotent
ses déchets après trois semaines de mer
dans les porte-conteneurs et puis les
risques environnementaux avec les
pollutions des rivières et les
pollutions de la mer
alors justement avec cette décision la
chine entend défendre l'environnement
voyez ce que disait le président chinois
en décembre dernier d'ici 2030 nous
allons réduire notre intensité carbone
de plus de 65%
la terre est notre seule maison commune
travaillons ensemble pour progresser
régulièrement dans la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord de paris et lancer un nouveau
voyage pour l'action climatique mondial
alors on a d'un côté le président
chinois qui affiche aujourd'hui son
engagement pour la planète dans le siège
des accords de paris et puis finalement
de l'autre des pays occidentaux qui se
retrouveront disait avec un veuf déchets
sur les bras et qui se serait bien passé
de telles mesures de la part de la chine
on a le sentiment d'un paradoxe alors
qu'est ce qu'il révèle bailly révèle que
le président chinois s'est manier quand
il le faut les grands mots et parler du
changement du des perturbations
climatiques alors que le vrai problème
en l'occurrence c'est celui des des
déchets et il révèle aussi que aux états
unis et dans l'union européenne est bien
là aussi a eu un maniement de grandes
phrases mais pas d'investissements pour
recycler in situ les déchets produits
par les consommateurs européens et que
la solution transitoire de faciliter
d'expédition des déchets vers la chine a
vécues
un temps un temps relativement court et
il était prévisible que ce temps soit
court parce que quand le trafic a
commencé
la chine n'avait pas de filière de tri
mais maintenant à partir de 2010 2015
ils ont compris qu'ils avaient assez de
déchets produits sur leur territoire et
qu'ils en auront de plus en plus
d'ailleurs
vu l'augmentation du niveau de vie en
chine et qu'il fallait couper les ponts
avec les déchets venus des etats-unis et
de l'union européenne
merci beaucoup avoue jacky bonnemains
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes directeur de l'association
robin des bois